sir you is this eric trump are you eric
trump are you here to respond
yes i don't like the way that everyone
is talking about me and my father what
what's wrong eric are you
why are you so upset
am i under oath you're you're on a
podcast you're not under oath but you
are live i played the fifth
the fifth
do you know what the fifth is
it's the first amendment
no plus two second amendments you're
like leticia james i didn't get the
answer that i wanted tell me the answers
answer my questions answer my questions
what you said last night on the hannity
show you know a lot of people on twitter
are really raking you through the coals
here they're calling you you know whiny
little [ __ ] and stuff is there anything
you'd like to tell the people out there
on twitter
i'm not a little [ __ ]
he was like oh man
hunter biden gets actual love from his
father
not like us
what do you think about the videos that
your brother does have you ever
considered doing these videos i'm
usually in the room and i'm the one
directing and i'm like
okay
eyes up
open eyes open
open your eyes so
i'm there i'm like i'm like a real
hollywood director but then i find out
later that i find out my dad's also into
pee go make some confetti go get some
coffee
oh really so you became confetti coffee
boy at that point when um yeah and
here's the thing spoiler that's where
kofi comes from eric i i really do
appreciate you coming on and um you know
giving us all this information i'm sure
it'll be very valuable to prosecutors
that are looking into you your father
and your family business wait wait no
you said you said this wasn't on the
record